before you were born  what did you see how dark was it inside  your mother's body pretty much no  visible light gets deep within our body  cavity but a uterus well inside a womb  at night this is what you would see but  during the day it might look more like  this in fact it can be bright enough  inside a womb to read a book inside a  womb covered with light clothing and an  averagely thick abdomen in direct  sunlight it can be as bright as an  overcast day or even a typical office  building it's a womb with a view oh also  if you shine a trio of Lights like this  at a human fetus in the womb it won't  really care but if you shine lights like  this it will look at them and follow  them why well the leading theory is that  this Arrangement more closely resembles  a human face and that even before we're  born even before we've met anyone we are  already looking for other people